when Israel was in Egypt slain let my
people go
Oh press so hard they could not stand
let my people go go down but Pharaoh
would not listen
so the plagues began first the water of
the Nile ran red with blood then Egypt
teamed with frogs and lice and wild
animals livestock fell ill and painful
boys covered everyone's skin
so Moses went to Egypt slain my people
[Music]
let my people go down let my people go
each time a new plague began Pharaoh
would promise to liberate the Jews yet
no sooner had the Lord ended the play
than Pharaohs heart with warden and he
would not keep his word and he did not
free the slaves so the Lord sent a hail
of fire a swarm of locust an endless
darkness the worst darkness where no one
could see their neighbor and finally the
tenth plague
[Music]
my people get Moses way down in Egypt
slave tell old Pharaoh let my people go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let my people go and at last felt
release the Jews from bondage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]